what we're going to do in this video is
think about the market for chocolate and
we're going to think about supply and
demand curves but we're going to get an
intuition for them in a slightly
different way in particular for the
demand curve we will think about the
idea of
marginal marginal
benefit
now marginal benefit when we talk about
margin it's really thinking about what
happens on the increment what happens
for each
little extra that you do so this is
saying what is the benefit that i get if
i get a little bit more of in this case
chocolate
well from the market's point of view
imagine if there was no chocolate but
there's people in the market who crave
chocolate who dream of chocolate if all
of a sudden they were able to get their
hands on some chocolate they would get a
huge benefit for that incremental amount
of chocolate maybe for these folks their
benefit which we could quantify as in
terms of dollars maybe their benefit is
fifty dollars per pound one way to think
about it they'd be willing to pay fifty
dollars because they get that much
benefit or if they paid less than fifty
dollars
let's say they paid ten dollars for it
well then they're getting forty dollars
of extra benefit of kind of surplus
benefit from being able to get it at
a price lower than their marginal
benefit
but then let's say the more chocolate
becomes available people still like it
but some of that really deep need that
deep addiction for chocolate has been
satiated and so the marginal benefit
tends for in most markets the marginal
benefit tends to go down as quantity
increases one way to think about it that
first initial amount of quantity if you
so we have some small amount of quantity
right over here i'll say delta quantity
that first quantity if you multiply it
times the marginal benefit
well that gives you an area roughly of a
rectangle like this it's not quite
rectangular at the top it's more of a
trapezoid if this is downward sloping
but you could approximate it as a
rectangle
but either way the area
right over here the area under the
marginal benefit curve you could think
about this as well what's just the the
benefit that the market is getting from
consuming this chocolate in this case
and so let's just continue on this trend
if there's more and more chocolate the
market will get benefit from it but
people aren't as excited about it
anymore they're they're saying oh well
the chocolate's around yeah it'd be nice
to have a little bit more but i don't
need so much more and at some point
people might be all chocolated out and
they get maybe even zero marginal
benefit from that incremental amount of
chocolate chocolate has filled up the
town there's nowhere to actually put it
now that won't always be the case you
might go someplace like that but either
way you think about it we would view
this as our marginal benefit curve and
notice this is exactly the same as a
demand curve in the market for chocolate
we have plotted price versus quantity in
the market for chocolate but we thought
about it in terms of marginal benefit
now on the supply side there's a related
idea we're going to think about marginal
cost
marginal
cost
so let's say at first there's no
chocolate being produced in this market
and a savvy entrepreneur says hey i know
some folks who are addicted to chocolate
they would get a lot of benefit from
from it so i'm going to try to produce
some chocolate and they look around and
they find out hey there's actually a
derelict chocolate factory in town that
no one is using and it's surrounded by
these wild cocoa bushes that are perfect
for chocolate and there are some people
in town who are actually unemployed but
they are amazing at producing chocolate
and so the that the first units of
chocolate it's the marginal cost to
produce it is actually quite low
but once you utilize those folks you
utilize that derelict factory utilize
those free cocoa bushes or whatever
cocoa trees well then you got to plant
new ones you got to train new employees
you got to build a new factory and so to
produce that next increment well that's
going to cost a little bit more and then
a little bit more and then a little bit
more which is the general trend in most
in most markets initially that first
amount you produce in this cheaper way
using the low hanging fruit as possible
but then you got to go up the tree find
higher and higher fruit maybe i'm mixing
metaphors
but your cost your marginal cost per
unit goes higher and higher and higher
now what have we constructed here well
you might say hey sal that's a marginal
cost curve but once again this is also
could be viewed as the supply curve for
this particular market
now what is happening at these low
quantities right over here
well the cost of production
is let's say they produce this delta q
amount
the cost of production would be the area
right over here under the marginal cost
curve that would be the cost of
production but they're able to sell it
the benefit to the market i should say
would be the total area under this red
curve would be the benefit to the market
the total area under this curve so if
you have the total
benefit to the market you take out the
cost then what you have in between these
curves
you could view this as a surplus you
could view this as a surplus benefit
right over here
so let me write this down this is
surplus and you won't hear this term but
i like to use it because it makes it
intuitive on what we're talking about
this is surplus benefit so as long as
there's surplus benefit the suppliers
are going to say hey wow i can produce
this cheaply people have a people get a
lot of benefit for they'd be definitely
willing to pay
ten dollars a pound wherever i am if
people are getting this much benefit
they're definitely going to be willing
to pay ten dollars for it so i'm going
to produce some or actually i'm going to
produce some and i could even charge i
could charge anywhere in between these
areas maybe i could charge right over
here and i get some of the benefit and
then the consumers get some of the
benefit
but then
another maybe entrepreneur realizes hey
well there's more benefit to be had in
this market so they keep producing they
keep producing as long as there is
benefit here as long as the marginal
benefit is higher than the marginal cost
all the way until we get to that point
right over here
now what happens
what happens right over here when we
talk about just supply and demand we
talk about that's an efficient price and
efficient quantity but let's just think
about
we said up until this point it makes
sense to produce more and more and more
even this increment if we're already at
this quantity it makes sense to produce
even a little bit more because you're
going to have this cost you're going to
have this cost incur but then the market
could have all of this
the market could have all of this
benefit
which is larger than the cost and so you
say well as long as i sell it for
something in between we can split we can
split that surplus benefit so to speak
but once these two lines intersect and
we have the situation where our marginal
benefit
marginal benefit is equal to our
marginal cost well at that point there
is no surplus benefit now to be had
there's no really incentive to produce
more than this beyond this point your
your incremental cost of production your
marginal cost is higher than your
marginal benefit so if you actually
wanted to give it to someone for their
benefit you would be taking a loss or
even if you just think about the market
itself the the the society would be
incurring more incremental cost per unit
than they would be getting a benefit so
why even do it
and so this point right over here where
these two
lines these two curves intersect and
we've talked about this with just supply
and demand but when we think about it in
terms of marginal benefit and marginal
cost we think about this quantity right
over here let's just call it q sub zero
this is this quantity is considered
allocatively efficient allocatively
efficient
which is a very fancy word allocatively
efficient
why is that the case well any other
quantity would not be efficient for
example let's say for some reason we
were at this quantity right over here
let's say
q
q
1.
well what happens at this quantity right
over here
well at this quantity
at this quantity right over here the
marginal benefit is higher than the
marginal cost
marginal benefit is greater than the
marginal cost and so we're leaving a
bunch of stuff on the table the market
is leaving a bunch of surplus benefit
you could say total surplus on the table
and so this benefit that the market
could have had but it does not get this
is called a deadweight loss
dead
weight
loss and we talk about it in other
videos remember in the allocatively
efficient quantity we have this huge
total surplus which is the area under
the marginal benefit curve and above
the
marginal cost curve up until the point
of intersection but if you do a quantity
less than that allocatively efficient
quantity your marginal benefit is higher
than your marginal cost and you are
leaving you are leaving all of this
total surplus on the table regardless of
how you would have actually allocated it
or distributed it between the consumers
and the producers
and what if you produced a quantity
larger than the allocatively efficient
quantity once again very fancy word so
let's say that's q2 what happens over
here
well here
you you're able to take advantage of all
of this surplus right over here this
this total surplus right over here but
now you're creating negative surplus
so
in this part
now all of this area
shows a net
a net negative benefit or a net i guess
i would say a net cost that our market
is incurring and so this here it was a
deadweight loss because we were leaving
stuff on the table that we could have
had here we're producing at a at a cost
that our market not just our suppliers
are producing the cost the benefit our
market is getting is less for each
incremental unit is less than uh
or is far less than the cost and so we
are incurring a net negative total
surplus and so this 2 would be
considered this 2 would be considered a
dead let me write that in a color you
can see a dead
weight loss deadweight loss we often
assume it was hey we're leaving some
total surplus on the table but we also
have dead late dead weight loss in the
case where we are producing
unnecessarily because the benefit is
less than the actual cost and so whether
our marginal benefit is greater than our
marginal cost or in this case our
marginal cost is greater than our
marginal benefit we are going to produce
dead weight loss in either situation and
a properly functioning market should be
producing the quantity that is
allocatively efficient in an ideal world
and of course all of our models assume a
lot of assumptions to make things a
little bit cleaner so we can do lines to
describe market behavior